hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
Devil May Cry 5 is finally here the
problem is it's been 11 years since
Devil May Cry 4 released so Dante story
is likely to be a little hazy for most
of us so I thought we should go through
the entire narrative of the first four
installments but of course they happen
in non chronological order so we'll put
them in this order to get the best out
of them if you ready let's do this
Devil May Cry is based around the myth
of Spada a demon who grew to love the
human race so much that he chose to
fight to save them you know what this
young lady can explain it better than me
long ago in ancient times Adina rebelled
against his own kind for the sake of the
human race with his sword he shut the
corner to the demonic world
and sealed the evil entities off from
our human world but since he was a demon
himself his power was also trapped on
the other side but I discovered that
this so-called legend was sparta existed
welcome back to Spyder soon enough but
now it's time to meet one of the sons of
Spada and the hero of this piece Dante a
demon hunter who is on the verge of
opening his first Devil slaying
organization sorry
not open for business yet I haven't even
picked a name for this joint and I'm
already getting calls
moments later this totally friendly
looking guy Arkham walks into Dante's
brand-spanking-new shop with an
invitation it's your name Dante son of
Sparta what did you do
from your brother
he sent this invitation for you please
accept it
Dante's twin brother Virgil awaits him
at the peak of this spire which
literally just sprang up so of course
Dante killing thousands of demonic
spirits in the hopes of ascending that
spire
which as it so happens is a Hell Gate
known as the teman II group which was
sealed underground by Dante's dad Spada
after defeating the hellhound Cerberus
Dante pops into this young lady who is
out to kill all demons at this point
that does include Dante but he knows how
to make a good first impression
as we're introducing characters here
meet this gesture the most annoying
character in DMC history who acts both
as a help to Dante and to some degree an
antagonist plot twist number one it
turns out Arkham and lady are related
shocking I know dad wins this battle but
not without losing a little blood my
darling daughter
[Music]
[Music]
so imminently lady will fall to her
death but luckily Dante's got a coat let
me go let you go
[Music]
[Music]
she really doesn't like Dante keep
trying pal keep trying so our hero
reaches the top of the teman II grew and
faces off with his brother Virgil
surprisingly Virgil kills Dante and
takes is amulet but by returning to stab
his own sword through his brother's
torso activates Dante's devil Jean it
awakens his devil trigger
I see a devil inside you has awakened as
well wait
we should leave for the moment we have
all that we need Dante and lady cross
paths once more this time is not as
far-fetched as surfboarding a rocket
dante jumps out of the flying whale's
eyeball just you know standard stuff
they even fight side by side in the next
gunfight back over to Virgil who decided
he doesn't trust Arkham anymore
to further your study of the Black Arts
you sacrificed your loving wife to
become a few moments later lady stumbles
across her dying father
yes I was manipulated
manipulated by a devil
named for Virgil
she's very easily manipulated but now
lady has yet another mission in life
taking down Virgil speaking of Virgil
he's now reached the ceremonial chamber
in the technique were using his mother's
amulet and the little bits of devil
blood he attempts to open the door to
the demon world suddenly Dante arrives
and the two battle once again each sword
strike further completing the ceremony
remember that gesture from earlier well
he's more integral to the story than you
think
his master plan was to have the Hell
Gate opened and Dante Virgil and lady to
be present at the exact same time here's
another plot twist the gesture is in
fact occurs and the final thing needed
to open the doorway to the demon world
innocent human blood let's welcome chaos
so the spire grows again and Dante races
back to the top of it using a motorcycle
and riding straight at the wall because
why the heck not on top akun completes
the ceremony and takes control of Spada
sword and thus now controls his mythical
demon powers dante wins the battle but
of course this boss has more than a
single stage
luckily virgil makes a dramatic entrance
and helps his brother defeat the devil
spawn in the scene which we just need to
watch because it's bloody great
I'll try it later
jackpot
[Music]
not very classy for someone's dying
words with Arkham defeated both Virgil
and Dante jump through the hell gate to
recover their side of their mother's
amulet and begin to fight for spiders
sort so yet again the brothers do battle
but this time dante wins as the portal
between the underworld and the human
world closes virgil decides to stay and
fight for power in the underworld oh by
the way as aachen was dying back in the
human world
lady catches up with him she's not a
pushover anymore okay no loose ends so
that's the end of the first part of the
story but dante still needs a name for
his demon hunting shop lady is on hand
to help a brother out
[Music]
are you crying
it's only the right
[Music]
maybe somewhere out there
devil may cry when he loses a loved one
don't you think devil may cry
this feeds nicely into the next DMC game
which is the original from 2001 on the
ps2 as Dante closes up shop for another
night a mysterious woman comes a-calling
and of course she knows everything about
Dante you're the man who lost a mother
and a brother to evil 20 years ago the
son of the legendary Dark Knight Sparta
mr. Dante Trish tells us about Mundus an
ancient evil bugger once imprisoned by
our dad Sparta we found out that the
portal between worlds can be found in a
castle on Malay Island so off we popped
to save the world yet again but before
we do that Dante is awestruck by Trish's
beauty it goes deeper than that though
as she looks almost identical to his now
deceased mother anyway over to Malay
Island this place is full of demon
spirits and more locked doors than every
Resident Evil game combined as Dante
slowly uncovers more clues to moon
disease plan we meet someone very dear
to our hearts our twin brother a
champion for the underworld is sent to
defeat humanity's champion our first
clue that this warrior is virgil is
during the first fight when he can't
kill dante after seeing his Hamlet
[Music]
we fight the dark night a few more times
but not until the final battle does he
reveal his true identity Virgil who was
last seen leaping into the demon world
I guess that plan didn't go too well for
him upon finally defeating our brother
he drops his side of their mother's
amulet and Dante allows himself a moment
of reflection
[Music]
Dante carries on slaying demons and
Devils with each noting similarities to
the legendary Dark Knight spider things
are going smoothly here so it must be
time for a plot twist and here it is
following Virgil's defeat Trish is
revealed as a servant of mundus who is
now tasked with killing Dante
Daunte benches down into the underworld
to do battle with demons on their own
turf but then trish does this you fool
you're so easy Trish you humans what
sweets you should know better than to
trust a stranger your presence has
become a hindrance to my Master's [ __ ]
scheme
she wasn't really much of a threat and
as the battle ends Trish is about to be
crushed to death but Dante seeing his
mother in her face races over to say you
may look like my mother but you know
we're close to her you have no soul you
have the face but you'll never have her
fire
[Music]
Dante finally cumference moon days but
is distracted by Trish who is about to
be murdered by the underworld boss
luckily Trish has had a change of heart
and throws herself in front of the
killing blow meant for Dante now the
final fight really begins as moon
distance ends his statue and Dante fully
embraces his father's mantle as the
legendary Dark Knight long story short
Dante wins and the ruler of the
underworld is no more back at the temple
Dante speaks to Trish and delivers the
greatest line in DMC history to fill
your Dark Soul with lie
[Music]
his final act is to give his mother's
amulet and far the sword to Trish who
proved Devils can be good they just need
a little help little nudge in the right
direction as Dante escapes the island
before it completely falls to pieces
moon distros everything at Dante in one
last attempt at taking control of the
human world Dante can barely damage moon
dish and things look bleak until
[Music]
Tricia's okay who'd have thunk it she
must have been sleeping earlier now with
moon dis defeated Trish and Dante share
a cheeky moment of love Trish
dunt Trish Devils never cry
these tears tears are a gift only humans
have
[Music]
a plane randomly falls out of the sky
because stuff happens like this and the
two survived the destruction of the
island to commemorate their touching
moment Dante renamed his shop as devil
never cry but don't worry he's just a
fat he doesn't stay there for long now -
Devil May Cry - which has been moved
around in the Canon order of the series
but now he's fully confirmed to have
happened before Devil May Cry 4 and
after the original Devil May Cry it
doesn't really offer much in terms of
law to the series so we'll fly through
this as quickly as possible as Dante
Trish and lady all begin to work
different jobs the group have many more
correspondents across the globe
one of which calls Dante this is Lucia
who tells the son of Spada to meet her
here bit dramatic love he could have
just said as the two arrived everything
blows up again all for drama purposes or
by the way throughout this game
Dante flips a coin to decide his
decisions leaving everything to fate
such as will he help Lucia and her
mother Mattia course he will is a
lovable scamp the big bad guy in this
game is arias who is trying to track
down a bunch of these items called
Arcana to raise a demon named Argus acts
after collecting each of these artifacts
Lucia confronts arias who throws a
spanner in the works revealing that she
is indeed a clone made by him Lucia
attempts to take down arias but is
captured luckily though Dante is here to
hand over all the Arcana needed to
summon a demon God in return for Lucia's
life Lucia is pretty mortified by this
but Dante used a little bit of his
cunning switch in the coin Arcana for
his own coin the one he's so addicted to
flipping Dante fights arias and
absolutely smashes him to smithereens
and the story is done well almost
it seems that Lucia hasn't got over
being a creation of arias
kill me kill me and everything will be
over hang on though before Dante can
decide what to do next the door to the
underworld opens as arias was able to
partially summon a gas axe Dante knows
what he has to do what are you doing my
job is hunting Devils once you enter the
demon world you may never be able to
return I'll go
an expendable you don't need to worry
about me
I'm happy if I can die like a human no
Devils never cry
how does he find the time to get these
chat up lines in every single game what
a guy
inhale Dante defeats Argos acts and
rides deeper into the underworld
unknowing if he'll ever return oh and
remember the coin he loves he is the
payoff
[Music]
hence
[Music]
you tricked me so zero of his decisions
were tempted by fate dante is the master
of his own future
oh and dante isn't lost in hell at the
end of the game he's heard returning
home on his motorbike before our next
story starts we have to jump in time a
little dante is definitely a little
older here in DMC 4 which begins in the
town of Fortuna a religious place set up
to worship the demon spoda previously
virgil visited the area and this young
lady was quite enamored fast forward
nine months I mean almost two decades
and we witnessed an injured man named
Nero frantically attempting to get to
the religious festival to see his
girlfriend sing in a few Beyonce
classics out of nowhere dante leapt
through the rafters and straight up
kills the oddest high priests Oh
extra points for the splashback quick is
a badass Nero takes on Dante and that
injured arm is revealed to be a semi
dormant devil gene known as the devil
bringer just waiting for a fight Nero
seems to have enough raw talent to best
Dante if only for a few seconds and with
that Dante leaves so what does a demon
God worshipping cult do when their
leader is murdered they use a secret
bunker to resurrect him of course down
here we also find out that the hierarchy
inside the order are actually the bad
guys of the story they are hell-bent on
becoming demons both the high priest
Sanctus and the head scientist agnes
have both achieved this goal already
they do this by using Virgil's sword
Yamoto which we last saw virgil using
the underworld the sod houses demonic
powers which is slowly siphoned to build
a modern-day demon Nero follows the
order into the secret bunker and is
attacked by Agnes it looked like nero
was a goner but Yamoto decided it wasn't
his time and joined his battle giving
him increased demon abilities
near always forced to fight his
girlfriend's brother who so happens to
have achieved demon Ascension Nero gets
the W but his girlfriend Keary a catches
up at the time when Nero looks like the
real demon in this fight tough break
seeing a chance to benefit Agnes kidnaps
Kira a while all of this is happening
dante keeps an eye on Nero's progress
such as sending in this femme fatale to
assist him but who is she
it's Trish when the time is right
Dante fights and defeats Nero to claim
back his brother's sword at the last
second changes his mind commenting and
keep it now it's a calm and cool keep
going it turns out that the oddest plan
is to summon a large demon to attack
their home town it's shaped to look like
the second coming of Spada forcing those
non-believers to sit up and repent
Nero goes for the killing blow on this
monstrosity but the age-old issue of the
bad guy having your girlfriend once
again prevents the swift resolution now
trapped Nero has no chance and your moto
is taken away from him remember kurios
bro well he tries to do the right thing
and of course dies on the outside dante
has been busy hunting down and killing
agnes claiming back his brother's sword
closing an amateur hell gate and finally
defeating the spider manifestation by
hitting big blood weak spots culminating
in a good old stab through the chest
with Virgil's saw do moto
now free Nero claims the sword and fight
Sanctus to end this nightmare
[Music]
[Music]
the story ends with Nero embracing his
heritage and using his freaky funky
demon arm to protect mankind so what
happens next as DMC 5 begins Nero has
his own mobile version of Devil May Cry
his devil bringer arm has been savagely
removed in the game's introduction and
replaced with cybernetics made by Nico
and get this she's the
great-granddaughter of nel Goldstein the
creator of Dante's iconic evany and
ivory jackpot so there we have it I hope
this was helpful and you're ready to
slay more demonic beings I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been an
absolute pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]